jean marie bigard
alors que
je me dis ah bon bonsoir il est vraiment
là
là bas ils ont qu'à l'arrivée c'est dur
il est vraiment
rien
j'explique à nos amis téléspectateurs
donc j'ai demandé à tous les invités ce
soir de me poser une question et de
poser une question à laurent baffie c
est ce que tu as déjà envoyé les stocks
de bois sont à canal parce qu'il n'y
avait rien dans ma loge avec un verre en
plastique ça sent la fin
arles est désolé comment tu as pu le
faire virer comme une merde comme ça et
moi et pour le lot ben je suis content
qu'il soit bien et avec toi parce que
comme ça il va écrire un sketch ou deux
pour moi on va en parler d'abord orange
en est qu à celle préparée cette
dernière émission j'ai trouvé un truc
drôle c'était toi un soir ici paris
ouais j'étais drôle vrai vas-y fais
péter allons d'abord il faut que tout le
monde dise manito serge 1 2 3